miles de personas están en las calles de
glasgow y han atravesado la ciudad
pidiendo justicia climática hay música
pancartas incluso instalaciones como
estas de extinción rebelión en la que
ponen a algunos de los líderes de los
países responsables del cambio climático
entre rejas y con esposas como vemos en
las imágenes piden justicia climática
qué quiere decir eso que la crisis
climática deje de abordarse desde un
punto de vista meteorológico económico y
político y que se incluyan los derechos
humanos en la discusión también piden
que los países más responsables del
cambio climático se hagan responsables y
pongan los recursos económicos como
llevan prometiendo desde el 2009 esos
100 mil millones de dólares anuales para
que los países más afectados por el
cambio climático puedan adaptarse a él y
mitigar sus impactos es una de las
marchas globales que se ha dado aquí en
la ciudad anfitriona de la cob 26 en
glasgow escocia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
d